[Musique]
dans 48 heures à cannes ce sera le
palmarès de ce 40ème festival et ce soir
on va retrouver bernard rapp et l'on va
évoquer le film les ailes du désir de
wim wenders dans lequel peter falk l'ex
colombo est un ange
je savais que j'avais peu de temps
c'était un dur à cuire
ma femme me l'a vite mais je serai bien
faire parler
il était là quelque part derrière ces
murs chambre 745 c'était pas le moment
de flancher
bonjour lieutenant je voudrais poser
quelques questions allez-y vous étiez
vous ces derniers jours bah écoute et
j'étais un peu à paris ou new york le
songe laisse un peu à cannes au think un
seigneur je vous ai vu dans un film
poussière ou le danger la preuve
qu'elles prouvent ces images regardez le
oui
cette sorte
non j'ai pas vu se créer que j'ai rien
vu du tout mais quand en ville m'a
appelé j'étais vraiment emballé parce
que jouer un ange ça me faisait plaisir
mais comment est-ce qu'on peut jouer un
rôle dans je jouais un ange
soyez vous même tout le monde est à vous
vous sentez comme un ange quelque part
oui tout le monde parlait bien loin du
personnage de columbo
non pas du tout colombo si vous savez
qu'en france les femmes vous avez
beaucoup je vous le confirme
alors là trouver une petite sur la page
on aimerait bien vous la montrer
maintenant ça crée poule est en vérité
elle venait là tous les jours caché
derrière ses lunettes noires
feliz et scarlett
et n'hésitez pas à montrer de la nature
l'avait plutôt gâté
puis ces hommes ou ces hommes qui
tournait tout tu veux manger petits
gâteaux dans les champs pantalon
[Musique]
elle était sérieuse
elle voulait faire du cinéma un point
c'est tout comme tout le monde ici à
voir sa photo
nos studios harcourt parmi les plus
grands parcours 50 ans de niche et de
stars
et cette année quittent était possible
y'avait qu'à demander
alors on a demandé pour elle c'est la
part de colombo colette et voilà le
travail vieux temps
[Musique]
kamala ça sera pas une copine à vous je
n'ai pas de commentaire à faire sur la
fille parce que moi je suis un ange les
deux stars aujourd'hui un triple à
tignes on a parlé et puis